we had a ditch next to our house like a  big ditch  i mean a ditch it was just a ditch and  and i hated my neighborhood so much and  i would sit down  sit out and just stare into the ditch in  the cold  when i was in third grade i just sit up  there  what  that's the story  that you looked at the ditch i would  stare into it for hours what were you  hoping come out like pan's labyrinth  there was nothing to do dude it was it  was i was what i would argue  i would argue a peak depression time in  my life third grade  oh my god  that's sad yeah i thought i would have  maybe maybe would go because it was a  good start i thought you were gonna at  least say you rolled around a ditch you  took some tonka trucks you rolled them  down and up the ditch you just stared at  it there was a little creak in it that i  fell in once or twice  wait a minute how long did your  relationship with the ditch go on  that ditch was a huge part of my  childhood